congratulations tonight to the class of  2020 at Doral Academy 47 graduates took  part in a special ceremony tonight that  included a fireworks show finale these  are the very first seniors to graduate  from the Charter School it means so much  for our seniors who you know they missed  out on their senior prom and all of  their their senior trip and grad night  all of that amazing stuff so we luckily  we only have 47 graduates since this is  our first class so we were able to put  together a socially distance  drive-through  it was a party and everyone kept safe  everyone wore masks and after the event  they spent some time singing and dancing  and hanging out in the parking lot what